elizabeth warren who was the head of the
congressional panel overseeing the
government's troubled asset relief
program
known as tarp her name has been
mentioned as a possible candidate to run
the new consumer finance protection
agency she spoke at the net roots nation
online media conference
over the weekend on my date with my day
job i'm a consultant and i work for
a number of progressive organizations
and one of the issues i work on is
economics
and the reason that i do that is because
for as long as i've been involved in
politics
i've noticed this gap on the progressive
side when it comes to economics
on the conservative side you know we all
know what their story is about the
economy
it's prosperity depends on low taxes and
no government
and no regulation it's trickle down
economics
where the rich get richer and the rest
of us get trickled down on
and i have to say as a new mom i feel
like i know the true meaning of trickle
down
better than anyone right now and it's
really no way to run an economy
but for progressives our story is much
less clear
we we do know what our values are and we
know that we want an economy based on
those values
we also have a ton of specific policy
ideas that
if we could enact them would make a just
economy
but when it comes to really a clear
coherent
um concise narrative that ties this
policy together
and that really paints a picture of a
bold
progressive alternative to the economy
we have now we still have a lot of work
to do
and that is really the point of this
session and the purpose of this session
today
we're in the beginning stages of this
and we don't have it figured all out yet
but for us in net roots nation the point
was really to
start the conversation so we've got six
great minds with us today to help us do
that
and these are people when you say the
words progressive and economics together
in the same sentence
these are the people you want to have on
the stage they each represent a
different piece of the puzzle
of the things we should be thinking
about and talking about as we work to
craft and create this argument and
narrative
so we're going to hear from the top
woman working to overhaul the banking
system
from one of the most important policy
makers in dc and from many of those on
the ground
fighting the good fight against big
banks big oil and big corporations
so without any further ado let's get
going
our first speaker is elizabeth warren
we're really lucky to have her um not
only has she been one of the most
important progressive voices for reform
in the wake of the financial crisis
most recently she has really has a long
career of standing up and fighting for
the middle class
she's a professor at harvard law school
served as the head of the tarp
congressional oversight panel
and if this room has anything to say
about it hopefully she'll be the head of
the new consumer financial protection
agency
please join me in welcoming elizabeth
warren
thank you dear thank you thank you thank
you
oh thank you
thank you thank you
thank you thank you
thank you and thank you jen
my grandmother when she was a teenager
drove a wagon in the land rush that
settled
oklahoma her mother was dead and her
little brothers and sisters were in the
back of the wagon
her father had ridden ahead and tried to
find a piece of land that might be
somewhere near water
a hard task in oklahoma um she grew up
in that part of the world she met my
grandfather uh
they got married they started building
one-room school houses
and uh little modest homes across the
prairie
they had kids they stretched they
scratched they worked hard they made a
little money
and they put it aside put it in a bank
got completely wiped out
in 1907 in an economic panic
but like many american families they
came back they started scratching and
stretching again and having more babies
and then the depression came and they
got wiped out
one more time you see my grandmother was
born into the world of
boom and bust boom and bust as it had
been
from 1794 until the great depression
but my grandmother also lived in a world
of economic transformation
because coming out of the great
depression just
three laws fundamentally altered
the course of america's history the
first one
fdic insurance make it safe to put money
in banks
the second one glass steagle try to
separate the risk taking on wall street
from uh your local community bank and
the
third one uh sec regulations
provide some cops to watch the robbers
and so out of that what we got
out of that what we got was 50 years
of economic peace no financial panics
no meltdowns and during that 50 years
we built a strong and prosperous
middle class in america now
my grandmother when she died
in 1970 at the age of 94
had been part of that she owned a little
house
she had plenty of groceries in the
cupboard and she had some
cash in the bank she was part of the
growth of middle class of america
as were her children and her
grandchildren but shortly after my
grandmother died within a few years
we began unraveling that part of it was
on the regulatory side
we hadn't been clever about regulations
they stayed ossified the regulations put
in place in the 1930s
had not been updated they had not
adapted to a new world
and along came a new group of people who
said let's just get rid of the
regulations what are they there for
anyway they just cost money dump the
regulations
and so the regulatory framework or the
cops
who are on the beat began to disappear
they lost their effectiveness
another thing happened in that period of
time
and that is the foundations of middle
class america began to erode
start with income income and
productivity
across america had been intertwined
after world war ii
so every year basically productivity was
going up
so were wages but starting in the late
1970s
those two begin to diverge so that
productivity
continues to rise indeed rise at a
somewhat steeper rate
while incomes flatten out so that today
a fully employed male makes less money
than his father made a generation ago
once we adjust for inflation
on the income side they're flat but on
the expense side these families are not
the core expenses for middle class
housing health insurance
day care college the things that make a
family
safer the things that make a family
middle class
the things that let them invest in their
children and the future
those went up adjusted for inflation by
more than a hundred percent families
spent more but they had flat incomes now
anyone here can figure out what happens
next and that is savings begin to
decline
families had put money away could no
longer do it
and debt begins to rise and families end
up with more mortgage debt more credit
card debt more car loan debt more debt
of
every form the credit industry
then smells an opportunity it says
wait a minute the old regulations are
gone
and middle class families are under a
lot of economic stress
there's money to be made in this
situation and indeed there was
at first it was just the money of
lending more
right more money led more more income
coming in got that one
but over time with the regulations
having changed
the business model itself changed
so that the old form of lending the
notion that you put the agreement out
there you can see what the interest rate
is
you can see how often you have to make
the payment and what the payment is
and that's the deal both sides get what
the transaction is
that model gave way to a very different
pricing model
a tricks and traps pricing model one in
which
the promise gets cheaper and cheaper
7.99 financing 3.99
financing zero financing
cheap cheap cheap why because the real
plan is to make the money on the back
end
the real plan is to bury the tricks and
traps in the fine print
and make really big money back there
now what's the consequence of doing that
well the consequence is families can't
price it
uh you can't tell up front how much it
costs to take out these credit
agreements
and more importantly families can't
compare
so the old notion of a competitive
market where you compare products and
the best products survive and the worst
products get washed out
goes away who can tell in here leave
four credit card agreements in front of
you
which one is actually the cheapest one
which is the one that carries the lowest
risk
without a competitive market the
consequence
is a big hole in the boat for consumers
on credit
so that last year you watch your numbers
about 150
billion dollars flowed out of the
pockets of ordinary middle-class
families
on penalty rates on penalty rates of
interest on regular rates of interest on
credit cards on payday loans on check
overdraft on kickbacks on car loans
all out there coming out of the pockets
of ordinary middle-class
families so that's where the market
stood
and now we are here at an historic
moment
three days ago president obama signed
into law
the strongest financial reforms
in three generations
and in my view the strongest of those
financial reforms
is the consumer financial protection
bureau
it's tough
and i want to be clear the president is
the one
who led on the consumer agency he
insisted it be in there
and he never wavered on that so
we have now the tools on the table
to make significant change the tools to
let us
get to a time when credit card
agreements can be two pages long
when it's obvious what the cost of a
mortgage is and it's easy to compare
across four mortgages or six mortgages
we can move to that time but
we've got to pick up the tools and use
them this agency
must be built it doesn't come think
about this statute that's just been
passed
it has a few pieces in it about changes
in specific law
but what it mostly is is about the tool
of the new consumer financial protection
bureau
so i i thought about i wanted to talk
with you for just a minute today
about what it is that we might do with
this bureau
what it is that when we're building
something new
what you want to build into its dna and
so i thought of four things that i
i at least would i thought of four
things that we should think about
as we begin to build a new bureau the
first one is
it must stand for families
we've had long enough where there's been
no one
to stand for families now what does that
mean it means in part
in the case of the credit agreements
that we've been talking about
a level playing field again it means
that there's someone there
to make sure that both families
and lenders understand the terms of the
credit agreement
that it is as obvious to one side as the
other that when they come together
they get what this transaction is the
cost that we create
competitive markets so that the products
are our products that not only
are priced so that consumers can
understand them but they're priced well
in the marketplace but it also means
something else to stand
on behalf of families you know the
when when folks when powerful people
get together in our government
and they start to divide up where things
are going to go
when they start to make decisions about
who's going to be helped and who's not
going to be helped
there needs to be at least one person in
the room
who asks the question how will this
affect
americans families not just how will it
affect america's banks
not just how will it affect america's
businesses but how will it affect
america's families
one of the things this bureau can do
is be there on behalf of american
families now the second thing that i
think is really critical about this
agency
is it must be reality based
it's not good enough to have a great
theory and frankly
it's not good enough to have just a good
heart
it's got to be grounded in how things
really work on the ground and i'm going
to give you an example of that
um small banks if the consequence
of this agency is to put in enough
new bureaucratic obligations
that it crushes community banks
then the agency will not have been
successful
if the community banks are driven out of
business that creates more concentration
in the banking
industry the big get bigger and the
small go away
but it also means there are fewer of
those banks around
to lend to the small businesses that
we're counting on to restart this uh
economy and it means that families
themselves
have fewer choices between small banks
and big banks
and that's a choice we've got to
preserve so ultimately what this agency
has to be about
is yes the first one on the side of the
families but second
the side of creating workable realistic
markets sustainable markets over time
markets that work for consumers but that
also create
a viable functioning credit system
it's got to be part of what goes into
this third part
is the agency the the bureau the bureau
has to be able to grow and change
you know part of what went wrong in the
1930s
was that we didn't keep the rules up to
date um
the world changed around it the markets
changed around it how families behave
changed around it
but the rules were not changing they
were not
they were not vital and so what this
agency what we have to think about when
you're building in at the beginning
is how do you build change how do you
build some creative destruction
into the agency itself you know i come
from the world of bankruptcy
it's what i teach bankruptcy is littered
with the businesses that didn't adapt to
the world
government doesn't have that same
discipline in it
and so part of building this agency
is building in how it will change and
adapt
over time that it has the right
structure to do that
and then the last part i want to mention
is part of why i'm here today
this will be the first agency we have
built in a wired world
think about that for just one minute the
relationship
between government agencies between
bureaucracy between the government
and its people at the time we built all
of the earlier
agencies was one of the government
labor's relative obscurity
and you send out some information and
people get it
through their newspapers or watching
television or radio or whatever they
listen to
this is an agency that will be the first
to be born digital
it will be an agency that can send
from its it will have the capacity to
communicate with millions of americans
by just hitting a send button it will
also be an agency where millions of
americans have the capacity
to communicate with the agency by
hitting the send button
and the possibilities here are
endless the notion that part of how one
comes to understand
and define the problems in the credit
area
will change if we hear if if this agency
hears if this bureau hears
from from people who are experiencing it
this is part of its
it can be built into the research
function of the agency
if the agency can hear from people and
communicate with people
it changes the concept of how
regulations work of how regulations are
tested
of how regulations are communicated and
how they are enforced
so i i think of this as a as a real
opportunity
as we build this agency not to replicate
what was built last time when we had a
consumer agency in the 1970s
but to try a whole new model to to to
think about this agency from a different
perspective
so that's why i came here today i bought
a plane ticket and showed up here
because i have a specific
ask i wanted to talk to people who have
a voice
and that's why i came to talk to you
there are
three things i want to ask you to do
with your voice
i want to ask you to use your voice on
behalf
of economic security for middle class
americans
in a world in which so many people face
so much in security i want you to use i
want you to give them voice
i also want to ask you to use your voice
for ideas this is the place to let
ideas be born to let them bounce around
to let them get tougher to let the bad
ones die out and the good ones advance
this is where ideas should come from
and the third is i want to ask you to
use your voice
as a voice of conscience in a world that
sorely needs
more conscience you are our collective
conversation
on conscience so i'm going to wrap this
up
by by saying we have an opportunity now
to pick up the tools that were laid out
in this new consumer financial
protection bureau
um and look unused tools
don't do anyone any good the point is to
pick them up and use them and it's going
to be tough
uh the era of my grandmother in the
great depression
it was tough then remember franklin
roosevelt faced his economic
royalists remember it took him
years to get his entire economic
package into place it paid off it was
tough but it paid off so what i want to
think about
is what we do from this moment going
forward
if you have any doubts about where we're
headed
and how much change we can make i ask
you for just
one second to glance back over your
shoulder
at where we have traveled over the last
year
um i was in chairman barney frank's
office just a few weeks ago and
barney frank deserves as much credit as
anyone on this planet for keeping this
consumer
financial protection bureau and making
it strong
so so chairman frank and i were talking
about some details
about the the bureau and what might
happen and not in conference
and we got to the end and barney looked
up and that way he does you know over
the top of his glasses
and he growled because that's the only
way i know to describe
a conversation with barney he said you
know elizabeth
a year ago this idea
wouldn't have even qualified as a pipe
dream
and here we are
and here's the best part of it when
you're thinking about what we can do
we're not here today because the banks
gave it to us
the banks did not a year ago say
well we're really sorry we broke the
economy
and um uh we really appreciate
that you put 700 billion dollars in a
few trillion in guarantees on the table
to help bail us out and therefore
we're going to support some regulation
for ordinary families to kind of level
the playing field
and just make sure that everybody's
getting a fair deal here
that you can read your credit card
contracts and mortgage agreements they
didn't say that
they fought us every single inch
of the way they they announced
of in august of last year that the
consumer agency
was dead and why was it dead because
they
were going to kill it they were quoted
in the new york times they were
that sure of themselves the lobbyists
came out
and said we will kill the consumer
agency
and they announced it and they
re-announced it and they re-announced it
they also announced its death over and
over and over if you check the papers
it was the agency was still dead as of
february
of this year but we didn't give up
we scratched and we bit and we hung on
and we didn't give up and today here's
where we are
with a good strong set of tools to
change
the consumer market
so let me wrap this back around
is this going to save the middle class
by itself the consumer agency
i've written about the middle class now
for two decades
and if you want to give me another
couple of hours i could binge your ear
about all that's happened here
and the answer is no there's frankly too
much that's broken
we've got to have change in labor policy
we've got to have change in health
policy
we're going to have changes in education
policy that's what it will take to
restore a middle class
but we also have to have changes in
consumer credit policy
and the new bill is a big step in that
direction
so here's what i want to say
one way or another i'll keep pushing for
the middle class
i hope you will too thank you thank you
thank you
excellent thank you
okay thank you elizabeth that was great
great to have her here
and you know in addition to to this kind
of sane regulatory framework that um
elizabeth's talking about and fighting
for we also need to think about the
american economy in the context of the
rest of the world
and no one has few people at least have
given that topic more thought than our
next speaker richard trumka
rich is the president of the afl-cio
where he
leads 56 national international labor
unions and about 11.5 million workers
and i also found out something about
today which is that
it's special day for rich not only
because he's here at networks nation
because it's his birthday so we thought
as netroots nation it would be only
appropriate to thoroughly embarrass him
by
singing happy birthday to him as he
comes out okay ready
happy birthday to
you happy birthday
to you happy birthday
dear richer
you're a bad girl
she promised that she was going to
embarrass me but i didn't think it was
going to be that way
it feels good to be 29 again i can tell
you
for the third time i have a few
announcements before i actually start
talking about
the subject that i have today i
understand out in the crowd is one of my
partners
linda chavez-thompson linda i don't know
where you are
but welcome
second of all i want to say as part of
the announcement there is only one
person
who should be the head of the consumer
independent consumer protection agency
and that's elizabeth warren
and the third thing is this is a
hera's facility and i'd ask you to do
something for me
we have a number about eight or nine
thousand hera workers in atlantic city
that have been trying to get a contract
with the auto workers for almost two
years harass hasn't been very
cooperative
so if you see any of the management here
please tell them
to negotiate in good faith and bring a
contract
to the auto workers in atlantic city
now as you said my name is rich trump
i'm president of the afl-cio
and i'm a third generation coal miner i
worked out of the mines in southwestern
pennsylvania
like my grandfathers before me both of
them my dad and both of his brothers
most of my uncles many of my cousins all
worked in the coal mine
as i did before i mean i got lucky uh
when i was in the coal mine the united
my workers saw something in me
and decided to send me on to college and
send me on to law school
and if it wasn't for my union quite
frankly i would not be standing in front
of you today
and i give thanks to them every day and
i give thanks to the men and women
who earn their living every day by
working hard
that's where i came from that's where i
started from
they sent me to college but i'm here
today to talk about
manufacturing and about making good
things uh in this country
and you see when when i was growing up
uh
the backbone of the economy through the
the 50s
and the 60s and the 70s was actually
manufacturing
we built the middle class and you heard
elizabeth refer to this
just a little bit earlier and i'm going
to show you a few graphs as well
to emphasize that point because from
1946 to 1973
in this country productivity doubled
and so did wages in fact it was the
greatest
distribution of wealth among any
civilized country that we've ever seen
but from the mid 70s and by the way
during that period of time
from 46 to 73
collective bargaining was about 37 or 38
density in the united states so
collective bargaining
was driving the wages for all americans
and as we produced more profit
workers made more as they made more they
were able to spend more
and the economy grew and quite frankly
everybody benefited
but from the mid 70s on while
productivity continued up
what you see is on that graph wages got
flat and that gap between the red line
and the blue line is significantly
different
as elizabeth told you wages have
stagnated people are making less now
than they did in 2000 family incomes are
down
workers tried everything to try to keep
pace with things
this graph shows you a couple of things
the yellow lines are
what happened to income in this country
between 46 and 73
and notice that the people at the bottom
of the spectrum the economic spectrum
were making where their wages were
increasing
faster than those at the top and so the
wage gap was closing
and then look at what happened from 73
mid 70s on to date the red lines
indicate income distribution during that
period of time
you see the people at the bottom with
nothing the people at the very top
the very two top lines the top tenth of
a percent
uh their income has increased 400
percent
the people at the the top 100 of a
percent their income
has increased off the charts here that's
people making more than 30.5 million a
year
and that didn't happen by accident
that happened because it was a
conscientious decision
and strategy in the united states to put
us on a path
of low wage high consumption strategy
because our economy is driven by
consumer spending 72 percent of it
and you couldn't do it without wages so
we had a strategy that said
we'll have low wages and high
consumption
so people borrowed they borrowed and
borrowed but it was a conscientious
decision
and i want to say this as well that
during that period of time
the people it was it's called
neoliberalism reagan and thatcher and a
number of others around the world
set us on this course where anything
that quote
distorted the marketplace ought to be
eliminated
regulations that are needed as elizabeth
talked about were eliminated
because they distort the marketplace
unions
because they bargained collectively and
spread the money around
more evenly and more fairly were
trying to be eliminated and so the
policies that occurred
from that point of time till this date
and in fact are still occurring
were designed to eliminate that
and if you look at the next page you see
that chart right there showing the
percentage of manufacturing
you see that manufacturing in this
country has continued to go down
and service sectors continue to go up
and
what i want to say to you is we really
cannot
survive as a nation unless we continue
to produce things
because as manufacturing goes
so does research and development it
follows the manufacturing
and we begin to lose our technological
edge
so we need to start thinking about this
in a bold way
we need to start thinking about this in
in a big way about how we can
recreate an economy that really is the
dynamo
that we have the potential to be we need
to make sure that
the real economy is again the the
superior to the financial economy and so
that the
financial economy doesn't continue to
suck funds
suck money out of the uh the real
economy and we're making things now
as i said we need to think big we need
to think bold
and we have to get out of this notion
that
gee we just can't do it we can't compete
in the world
because that's just not so we can
compete we can do it
we have to make sure that we want to do
it and we need to
create those good jobs and the american
people
to do that really need a vision
about those good jobs so i'm going to
talk to you a little bit about that
vision today
other countries are already doing this
right
germany during the recession hasn't felt
any
anywhere near as much pain as we have
because they have decided on a high wage
high consumption strategy where they'll
keep their wages up and they will export
china china during this recession
has seen they're investing in green
technologies at a rate much higher than
we are
they've invested 34.5 billion dollars
in developing low carbon energy
technology
that's nearly twice what we've invested
in the united states
and while we're planting 500 miles of
high-speed rail this year
they're planting 5 000 miles of
high-speed rail
they already have in effect so
the first question that people will say
always the ones that don't want to do
this
they'll say well my how are we ever
going to pay for
this well you know what i'm tempted to
say most of the time
you know we figured out a way to bail
out the banks who created this problem
we figured out a way to pay for wars we
figured out a way
to do everything that you've decided to
do if we
we can figure out a way to pay for these
jobs as well
and i think that wall street really
should start paying
their fair share of what they've done
and we can start we can start with a
twofer
a financial transaction tax will stop
speculation
and at the same time create 150
to 300 billion dollars that can be used
for job creation and all this
but if we're going to do it if we're
going to move from a low wage
a high consumption society to a high
wage
high consumption society then we have to
integrate all the policies
and there are four or five things that
i'm going to mention quickly
uh during the time that i have here we
have to integrate trade policy
we have to integrate tax policy we have
to immigrate
immigration policy and we have to fix
labor policy because as i said to you
and i'll get to this a little more
in detail in a little while
we have to have all of them together
after we've made a decision
as a nation that we want to produce
things again
so we're talking about trade policy
we need to the president said he's going
to double exports
and that's wonderful unless we triple
imports because for every dollar
of trade deficit we have it's a drag
on the gdp it slows down and destroys
job growth
so what we have to do is get net exports
up
and if we're going to do that we have to
start by enforcing our existing laws
they aren't being enforced they weren't
under eight years of
george bush but now we're going to see
them enforce the
the president starting that process we
have to stop letting people exploit us
with currency policy like china does
right now
and the pacific rim who has to follow
china
we can't support countries that murder
trade unionists like they do in colombia
we can't support blindly open up our
markets
to countries that won't open up their
markets
like south korea right now the trade
deals that we've been negotiating have
been
pretty much one-way streets for us
so we have to get good trade deals as
part of the deal
to have a manufacturing uh policy and a
global export policy
uh in this economy the second thing is
we have to deal with is taxes so
if you look at the the share on that
chart of
uh what corporate taxes have done you
can see that
they've really gone down uh over the
the last several years in fact they've
oh that's still on there i have a
monitor here and it disappeared and i
i thought they really went down they
went off the chart uh for a second
but you could see what they're paying
they're paying less than two percent of
gdp right now
well we're asked to pick up more and
more and more of the tax burden
and they're about to ask us to pick up
more in the form of
doing away with social security or
raising the age limit for people to get
it or
reducing the benefits all the little
things that they put more of a burden on
us while their tax burden has gone down
what we need
is a tax policy that encourages people
that produce and manufacture in this
country
not reward people who outsource and
produce things
around the world we have to close
we have to close the loopholes that let
corporations
really have record profits and at the
same time
use those gimmicks not to pay uh any of
the taxes that we have
so again we have to integrate tax policy
with it
i want to briefly mention one thing
before i get on to the
to the other two policies and that is
right now the country there's a big
debate going on
over whether we should do job creation
and stimulus
or deficit reduction uh
any economist right now
that says that we should not do job
creation but we should do debt reduction
right now
either flunked out of school
went to a matchbook school or is simply
disingenuous
because
all real economists will tell you that
we don't have a deficit crisis in this
country right now
what we have is a jobs crisis
and what we need if you want to get rid
of that deficit
is to create jobs and manufacturing does
a great job at that
look at this chart this chart tells you
what cause of the deficits are
and if you look at that big orange line
in the middle over 60 percent of the
projected deficits
come from one thing george w bush's tax
cuts for the rich
eliminate them and you start to
eliminate part of the problem
the other part if you look on the top is
from the two wars
the ones on the bottom of that chart if
you if you look at it
uh are from the recession and that
little bitty blue line that keeps
getting smaller
well that's the share of the stimulus
package and what we've done
for job creation right now so that
i'm sort of sick and tired of listening
to the demagoguery
and the hypocrisy of people particularly
in the senate
that say we can't do job creation
because of the deficit
on one day and then the next day they
stand up in front of the
the cameras and say oh by the way i'm in
favor of doing away with the
estate tax and i'm in favor of extending
the bush tax cuts
for the wealthy and i don't care how
they get paid for
you see that's the fight that we have
that's the fight that we have
collectively to be able to challenge
those type of people
and none of us none of our groups can do
it alone
but together together i really believe
that progressive groups can come
together and we can change this type of
demagoguery again back to the policy if
we're going to be doing
manufacturing we need to have training a
lifelong training program
that's delivered through high schools
and community colleges
for everybody that's out there and the
base of all of this
again is labor law reform because i
told you from 36 or 46 to 73
when we had 37.5 or 38
union density we were driving wages for
everybody
and we were sharing those productivity
gains in this country
across the entire country the middle
class was born
from 73 upwards our proto or our
density has dropped to 12 percent right
now 12
12 and a half percent we're not driving
wages for
anybody only through collective
bargaining a change in the law
are we going to be able to bring the
same type of middle class
money back from our productivity to the
vast american of workers out there
because if you believe that employers
will continue to do it out of the
goodness of their heart
i have oceanfront property in
southwestern pennsylvania
that i will shall sell you very very
cheap i might add
now so our job is to get back to a
high-wage
high consumption strategy
and one other thing that we really have
to look at
is an immigration policy
immigra immigration reform because right
now
employers
right now employers are
using the current broken system
to create a permanent underclass of
workers
that they use to drive wages down and
when you tie that
to the chamber of commerce's desire to
have
open flows of people into the country
even when there aren't shortages
and it's tough for me to believe there
are shortages when you got
15 million people laid off right now
if you talk about those things together
and we don't correct the problem with
immigration reform
then what we have is a continual
downward
downward pressure on wages
a downward pressure on enforcement of
the labor laws
we have to have comprehensive
immigration reform
and at some point when we have more time
i'll tell you about the several points
that we've come together on
in the labor movement and by the way the
labor movement
is unanimously behind
the five-point program that we're
pushing for comprehensive immigration
reform
that will lead to a pathway for
legalization
to the immigrants that are here and let
them come out of the darkness
and be part of the american dream
so that's our vision a vision where we
have high wages and we have high
consumption
a solid economy where everybody's
benefiting from it
not just the top two or three percent or
the top tenth of a percent
or the top 100 of a percent
how did i know mitch mcconnell came up
there
he's a good-looking guy don't you think
hey john boehner somebody told me they
saw better legs on a pool table than
that but
anyways we're going to hold these people
accountable just ask blanche about that
look
here's what i want to say to you here's
what i want to say to you very very
quickly
no one none of us thought this was going
to be easy there are people that say
they want to throw up their hands they
want to say i quit
but they they can't we can't because we
knew this wasn't going to be easy we
knew it wouldn't
take a year or six months to undo the
bush destruction
that it wouldn't take a year to take on
wall street
and to take on banks that went from 17
percent to 63 percent
of gdp no one thought it would happen in
a year or two
it's going to take a concerted effort by
all of us over a long period of time
because no movement has ever won in a
very very short period of time
it's taken fights it's taken years
sometimes the fights
and we're up for it and i look forward
to working with you
and this election this election is not
going to be a referendum about
uh barack obama or the congress this
election should be
a decision on each single race about who
is going to get us
closer to that vision that we have of a
high wage high consumption
strategy and who is going to take us
away you know who our friends are
let's support those friends let's kick
the other ones in the backside
and make them look a little faster move
just a little bit faster
and let me say this i look forward to
working with you
for a long long time and bringing this
country
some sanity and make it a progressive
america
that it can be god bless you thanks for
having me i really appreciate it
thank you
thank you rich trumka that was awesome
so in thinking about how we're going to
innovate
with new industries that put america
back to work the green economy is going
to play a central role
our next speaker is a key leader in
working to grow the green economy and
create new jobs throughout america
phaedra ellis lampkins phaedra comes out
of labor organizing herself
and is now the ceo of green for all one
of the country's leading advocates of a
clean energy economy
and creating green jobs that will pull
people out of poverty so please give a
warm
welcome to phaedra ellis lampkins
um
oh
so does anyone doubt that the economy is
in crisis
okay now i know this is net roots nation
but uh my expectation is that you'll be
awake even though i'm after elizabeth
warren which is kind of like
i just want to say i hope in my life
that i get to walk out on stage and just
my presence liberates people
i i joked with her i said you know
we get to meet famous people all over
the world and i don't think i've ever
been so nervous i
all she had to do is come out on stage
and just be like that's right
i'm here
so though i'm not elizabeth warren
i have to tell you i was thrilled to be
here because
this moment is an incredible moment one
in which we find both
the environment and the economy in
crisis
and there's really two things you do in
the midst of a crisis
the first is you bury your head in the
sand you start to watch glenn beck
you wait for the end to come and you
turn against one another
the second is that you think about how
to build an economy that doesn't rely on
depleting our natural resources
and offers opportunity for all people
so the real question is what type of
economy do we want
and we were talking in the room they
said lay out your bold vision for the
future
so my bold vision is really simple
everyone gets to prosper and we don't
destroy the planet doing it
now for me it's a really personal fight
and it's a personal fight because i know
what poverty feels like
and what's incredible about this moment
is that so many americans
are living in poverty they're facing
losing their paychecks they're losing
their homes
and for me you know i grew up in a small
town called sassoon city california
for those of you that don't know it's
famous because it's between
four refineries as you're driving down
interstate 80 in california you hit
richmond where there's chevron
go further you hit cnh where there is uh
also known as crockett
then you hit fairfield where there's
anheuser-busch and then you've arrived
in sassoon when you'd hit shell refinery
and so living between four refineries is
not where the best environmental health
was
so when i was a kid my mom took me to
the doctor because i had asthma and
allergies
and we went to the doctor and my mom had
left
a violent relationship had managed to
buy a house on a waitress's salary
and we went to the doctor and she really
walked in a proud
single mom who'd put herself through
school bringing her child to the doctor
and we went in and you know we had
medi-cal stickers which are the green
stickers you used to pay at the doctors
but
that's still she still was proud and we
went to the doctor and the doctor said
your daughter is sick because of where
you live
and you need to move now for my mom
moving wasn't an option but the
transformative moment for me
was that i walked in with a mom proud of
what she'd done
and i walked out with a parent a shame
that she couldn't take care of her child
and so the question for this room and
for our movement is
can we create an economy that stops
parents from having those moments can we
be bold enough to say
that we believe an economy that
represents all of us
is what we should have now i have to
tell you i wish i were one of those
folks who just does
good but i'm not um i do aspire to be
and i work on it every day
but i am here really selfishly and i'm
here selfishly because i have three
nieces
they have an addict mom a dad that just
got out of prison
and they still live in sassoon city
and shalimar jasmine and layla
they deserve better and i'm here because
i want you to join me
so that my girls have a better life so
that we
say to this country that we believe it's
not fair that parents have to choose
between their
jobs and their lives that when we see
what's happening in the gulf what we
recognize
is in this moment in this country
people still have to make a choice
between their lives their families and
putting food on the table
and that is not the best that we can do
so what do we do about it well those of
you who haven't yet been on the glenn
beck board of crime inc
and don't realize that what happens is
really nothing
and i mean i won't talk about him
because then it'll show up tonight and i
don't think he's important enough
i do want to say so what do we do so
here's what my big ideas
my idea is that we become job warriors
we are job warriors and what that means
is that
we recognize that the rights of a white
coal miner in west virginia
are as critical as a latina in south
central los
angeles that our movement can't just
care about one group or the other
that we have to be vigilant about this
economy
that we have to see we have to say that
every person
can participate so
we've done in the city of portland
what happened is we looked in portland
and we said how do you create a green
economy
so the first thing we did is we saw
incredible investment coming from the
federal government
and we said we want that to go to the
most vulnerable people
but we also want to not exploit the
planet and so we created a program that
focused on quality
and access it said how do you make sure
these are good jobs
that people have access to that reduce
pollution
and the good news is we've reduced
pollution 46
of the people working are either people
of color or women
and more importantly the people in that
community know that we care about jobs
now i wanted to make sure this was
interactive
because i know you're listening to a lot
of folks and i also know that the best
spokespeople
are the people themselves so all i've
asked you to be job warriors
i want you to meet two incredible
warriors who've committed their lives to
making change
for all of us please meet you'll meet
talia williams and you'll also meet
marquis bryant
you see i'm not taking as much time as
everyone else's so i don't think they're
ready yet
so they're going to fast forward why
don't you pretend on elizabeth warren
and just
amazing
i was growing up in a community that was
just
basically like heavily polluted my
little brother
he always had like breathing problems
growing up but i think that a lot of
that comes from this
from this freeway from these trains it's
just like it's just crazy and we have to
live here this is where we live this is
not
there's no toxic dump this is like my
backyard this is where we live
we need more cats from the hood to step
up into leadership positions
we will be locked out of this new
economy like we was locked out of the
old economy
so we have opportunity right now to be a
part of something bigger than we ever
thought
what we do is we weatherize homes which
we go out and cruise with threes and
fours
so some of the things we do is weather
stripping we switch out light bulbs to
energy efficient light bulbs energy
efficient shower heads
we check out the boiler make sure
there's no backdrops into the house
and what we're doing is to help cut down
on carbon emissions this is what i want
to do i want to make a career out of
this
because you know i'm also worried about
the earth itself you know
like it's not gonna nothing lasts
forever and i want to do everything i
can
to keep it safe for us you know to live
i just feel good that even though it's
small i'm doing my part
introduce you to those two folks the
reason i wanted to tell you the story of
what it felt like for me to grow up
is because we want you to know which is
what you know that not only is change
is possible this is a moment where
people hope that we'll turn against one
another
we'll spend the next nine months
focusing on who's where what they're
doing
and how we hate one another and who's
done what and who hasn't
or this is a moment where we come
together and say every person in this
country deserves to support their family
and live in a healthy community and
that's what this moment is about
it's about creating jobs for talia it's
about making sure that marquis is a
community where he doesn't have to live
near a freeway
and the real question is is our movement
ready for this moment
and i have to tell you that you know i
get to speak in a lot of places
and the reason there's two places that i
wanted to be this year
and this is one of them and the reason i
wanted to be here
is because i want to make sure that i
translate to you
how important your work is i want to
make sure that when we talk about what
the vision for the economy is
we don't let ourselves be separated that
when people say where are green jobs
that you cannot just say portland
detroit pittsburgh and other places
but that you know the story of talia and
marquis
and more importantly when someone says
why that you know shalimar jasmine and
layla
and that you recognize that an economy
that makes sure that those girls have
opportunity
is critical to what we do you know i've
spent the last week talking about a
climate bill
and i have to say it's been a you know
week that could have been somewhat
depressing
you know you have a vision for what you
think the world will be but it also
taught me a lesson
which is i let me just say to you i want
to blame the president
because it would be so much easier it
would be so much more fun
but the reality is our movement wasn't
ready and we were ready to have a bill
that compromised the clean air act so we
had something
and that's just not acceptable it's not
acceptable when you have
shalimar jasmine and layla and it's not
acceptable when you have marquis
centalia
so if our movement our movement will be
ready when we say
hell no to a bill that compromises the
clean air act
when we say hell no to a bill that
doesn't create opportunity for those
folks
and and my ask of you would be the next
couple of months we have to push back
but our pushback can't be about who gets
to be where about whether we like people
or we don't
our pushback has to be do italia and
marquise's life get better
because that's the only stick we want
people to measure us by
we don't want to be measured by what
someone else says we want to make sure
that a coal miner
in west virginia that a woman in south
central that marquis and those folks say
my life got better because at net roots
there was a conversation
and they recommitted themselves to an
economy that works
and they said that we want jobs for all
people you know we're not going to stop
thinking about how to do climate change
or clean air or other things because
it's not about what's said in the press
it's not about what anyone says we
recognize we're about
real people and we will measure our
success by do real people's lives get
better
because i have to tell you when i talk
to my family and i say you know
there's a problem with socks and ox and
mercury and ozone and
i just don't feel comfortable with this
bill here's what most of my family tells
me
is that going to help me save my house
am i going to make more money
will there be more parks for my kids
will i have unemployment insurance and
will have access to health care
and our answer has to be you don't have
to talk about mercury and ozone right
now
but what you need to know is our
movement is for you
we measure our success by the
improvement of your lives
and these stories have to lead because
at green for all it is green for all
not for some we want everyone to have a
common vision
and so what i ask you is are we ready to
make change for marquis
are we ready in this room are you ready
you know okay i'm gonna i am gonna go
because i'm gonna be on time and jenna's
gonna be impressed
but what's up with the back of the room
you know what i just i'm not gonna
repeat what they said okay i want the
front of the room to be quiet
are we ready
so are we ready for marquis
are we ready for an economy that
transforms all of us
i'm going to say green and i want you to
say for all
green for some green
thank you i want to end because i want
to show you what our vision truly is
it's time to go green we gotta go green
the food ain't fresh and the air ain't
clean from the hood to the birds
my family and friends and when i say i'm
going green to the hood and sound funny
but i'm talking about
saving the earth and getting money so
many leaders paid away for the leaders
of today these are the shoulders that we
stand on now we all hands on
thank you
good job
yay thank you phaedra i am impressed on
a number of levels so thank you for
being on time
so uh while we are talking about
building this new economy and
and building a movement for this agenda
outside of dc
we also know that our success is
ultimately going to be dependent on
some elected allies within washington
and so
our next speaker really needs no
introduction to this group
he has been a hero to the net roots
community for his bold leadership
on economic issues in congress from
fighting for corporate accountability to
standing up for working people in the
middle class
he was elected in 2008 to represent
florida's 8th congressional district
and serves on the financial services and
science and technology committees
please join me in welcoming congressman
alan grayson
greetings angry protesters
let me see the tea bags dangling from
your skulls
let us genuflect toward glenn beck's tv
studio
and now a moment of silence to show our
sorrow
that the democrats passed health care
reform for all america
let me tell you what every election is
about every election is about 309
million americans asking the question
what are you going to do for me and
that's fair that's what democracy is all
about
now that's a good thing because if they
asked which candidate is
better looking i'd be in big trouble
but that's not what people want to know
people want to know first what are you
going to do for me and second do i
believe what you are saying
and when i think about what it is that
the democrats
need to do i keep coming back to one
thing over and over again
and that is the fact that we need to do
more for working people in america
the middle class
now this is the first election i can
recall in a long time when neither party
seemed to be making much in the way of
promises to anybody
and i really wonder why we have good
ideas
we have things to offer so why aren't we
offering them to the american people
explicitly
what is our platform i want to try to
scope out for you what
that platform ought to be but what it
comes down to is this
at this point in our history
it's very simple people want to know
what the democrats are going to do for
them and people are afraid
of what the republicans are going to do
to them
so ask yourself this what is it that we
actually provide to americans who work
we make five poor promises to them
the first promises we promise you a
minimum wage
a minimum wage that barely increased
in nominal terms and declined sharply in
real terms
over the course of a quarter century a
minimum wage you could not
possibly live on what's the second thing
that we offer americans who work
time and a half for overtime unless the
bush administration regulations happen
to take that away from you
the third thing that we offer people a
safe workplace
as long as an ocean specter happens to
be right behind your shoulder
there are 135 million americans who work
do you know how many osha inspectors
there are
2 000 how many in the state of nevada
40 for the entire state and it's a
pretty big state
so we're going to have to do better than
that we promise
we promise people a workplace where you
will not have to face discrimination
unless of course the eeoc is being run
by people like clarence thomas
and we promised people finally the right
to organize
something that so many people men
women and children died for
so that americans could do that at
ludlow
at homestead at haymarket people died
so that we could have the right to
organize and we conditioned that only
one thing
we conditioned that on the employer
agreeing to sign a contract with the
union
that's all we ask for they just have to
be willing to sign a contract
isn't that ridiculous we leave it up to
the employers decide
whether we can unionize whether we can
organize what's the sense of that
we're going to have to do a lot better
than that if we want to have a real
medal class in america
here's one thing we need to do we need
to make sure
that everyone everyone not just the
people who work
but everyone every american can see a
doctor when he or she gets sick
now the bill that the democrats passed
accomplishes that largely
through government subsidies half of the
people who will be receiving
this benefit in the future will be
receiving it through medicaid
half of the additional people who will
be receiving the future will be
receiving it through private insurance
subsidized by the government
why don't we simply say that if you have
a job
then you have health coverage what's
wrong with that
in fact i can remember that in 1991
a completely unknown college professor
named harris wofford
ran for the senate in pennsylvania
anybody here from pennsylvania
and ran against someone who had been the
governor of pennsylvania
and had been the attorney general
his opponent had name recognition of 122
percent
22 percent of pennsylvania knew him and
wish they didn't
and wofford's name recognition was -7
they put fake names in the polls
and more people knew the fake names than
harris wofford
and yet somehow he won harris wafford
beat bick thornberg
how did that happen he made a promise to
people
that they believed he would try to keep
and that promise was very simple
if you have a job then you have health
coverage
that one simple promise now let's talk
about another promise
another promise that we should try to
keep and that's this
if you work for 30 years then you
deserve a pension
when i was growing up most people in
america who worked for 30 years got
pensions now it's down to about a
quarter of us
what happened who took our pensions
and what do we have to do to get them
back
we need to make sure that everyone who
works in america for 30 years has a
pension
that's the way it is in germany are they
better than us
do they work harder than us do they work
longer hours than we do
no so that's what we need to do for
americans who work
here's another thing paid sick leave
i ask people do you really want the guy
who makes that
hamburger fruit with mcdonald's to be
working when he's sick
do you want that what's wrong with that
do we literally have to force people to
choose between staying home when they're
sick and losing their jobs
no they have paid sick leave in
japan france england
germany italy even china
so we need to do that for us we need to
do that for
us now the last thing i suggest
is that we need to have paid vacations
why
because we are not slaves
150 countries all around the world
protect the rights of employees to paid
vacations even china
in fact every other industrial country
in the entire world
provides for paid vacations for their
employees except the united states
and i ask you for that not only because
i represent disney world
the happiest place on earth except for
washington dc
but also because it is just it is fair
it's right people deserve it we deserve
it
now i'll tell you this if the election
of harris wofford is any indication
if we promise these things to the
american people we in the progressive
movement
and we deliver on them
then we will run this country for the
next 50 years
as lincoln said there will be a new
birth of freedom
and government of the people by the
people and for the people
will not perish from this earth
what we are promising people is a new
new deal
are you with me they get on your feet
thank you congressman
so to actually go from as van said
yesterday from
despair to hope is kind of easy but hope
to change is really hard so
we really do have to build a movement
that is
outside of washington and big enough and
strong enough to
as our leaders often like to say make
them do it
so george gale is the director of
national people's action and he
is one of the many people playing a role
in making this happen
george has been an organizer and a
strategist and a trainer in the movement
for 15 years
crafted and ran campaigns nationally on
affordable housing
predatory lending and immigration
justice issues
at npa he has helped innovate and turn
around
the organization into one of the leading
grassroots fighters for banking and
financial reform
please join me in welcoming george gale
can you guys imagine what it would be
like if we had 50 congress people that
sounded like that
it would a much different country
at national people's action we believe
if there was ever a moment
to build a movement an
honest-to-goodness goodness movement
to create a more just and sustainable
economy
that moment is now and we think because
if you look back sometimes we forget it
but two years ago
unfettered capitalist greed was
literally on the ropes
gasping for air all but given the 10
count and without if it wasn't for
great government intervention who knows
what would have happened
and that's not lost on america but let's
be honest
one cross section of this country has
been in a recession for generations
many people are like what recession or
this feels more like a depression at
this point
but what's different is suddenly we have
a new section of the country
asking hard questions around the economy
let me see if i can make this thing work
i guess i can't there we go
um so that changes the equation
suddenly to have a new part of the
country saying
hey this is not working for me i'm
feeling a new level of economic
insecurity
and the questions that people are asking
and i travel across the country or not
how do we get back to the recession
pre-reception days of 2007
how do we get back to the economy we had
10 years ago
people sense something is deeply wrong
in this country and people are asking
big questions so suddenly we have a big
portion of the country
potentially a majority that is asking
hard questions about the future of the
economy
and as progressives we have an
opportunity and an obligation to put big
answers
in front of them i want to start by
introducing you to three members of
national people's action three of the
people that i work for
these are three women who've been
impacted by the crisis
who are asking tough questions about the
future of our economy
and who've joined the fight to hold
banks accountable this is farrell wagner
farrell is an 81 year old retiree in des
moines iowa she proudly refers to
herself as a member of the greatest
generation
her biggest concern is that her mother
lived to be 101
and she just doesn't see how her
retirement savings will stretch 20 more
years
all that concern became much more of a
worry when 30 percent of her pension got
wiped out after the big
meltdown next mitzi river singleton
wichita kansas single mother struggling
to keep the lights on went to get a
payday loan
and then she got into the terrible
vicious cycle of debt that makes up
payday lending
the average three hundred dollar payday
loan cost people 750 dollars
and mitzi pelta paid a hell of a lot
more than that by the time she was done
and trenda kennedy right now today trend
is fighting tooth and nail with bank of
america to save her home
she sent her papers to get her loan
modified
into bank of america 10 times and 10
times they've lost them
and then recently her son died in a car
crash
on the day she buried her son bank of
america called to collect
she said hey today is not the day but
they kept pushing
and pushing and pushing and any day now
trendy could lose her home
but the fact that these women have went
from being
a victim of the economic crisis to
fighters
in a movement for something bigger and
better speaks to a progressive
populist sentiment that though you
wouldn't hear about it on the media
is alive and well in this country
so i've moved too quick into these
slides
as we begin to think about building a
movement
we've got a tough question to ask
ourselves as we think about rebuilding
the economy
we have to decide are we going to try to
win an advanced
a few ideas to make this economy a
little bit more just a little bit more
sustainable
are we ready to say hey it's time to
chart a new course
we got to think bigger about what we're
going to do we got to
put a stake in the sand as progressives
and say
hey we are not here to tinker
and if we are not here to tinker if we
are here to think big
we got to know it will take a movement
anything less will not get it done
anything less means we're eking out
victories along the margins
anything less means we're talking about
a game of inches when we need to be
thinking about miles and miles and miles
so as we think about movement building
i don't know if anybody ever read the
book by jim collins called good to great
well jim collins is a stanford professor
and
his research shows highly effective
organizations
one of the great attributes about them
is they are willing to face the brutal
facts
they're willing to look at the hard
truths and face those but with an
undying certainty that they'll succeed
so as movements it plays out the same
way and we've got
two hard truths that we got to face
one there is no way that you build
a more just and sustainable economy
without directly
challenging the power of wall street and
big corporations in this country
there's simply no way to get from a to b
without changing our relationship with
corporations and as we've learned in the
fight
for health care reform as we've learned
in the fight for financial reform
and as we've learned in the fight for
climate change
that until we reclaim our democracy from
big corporations we cannot begin to
reshape our economy
hard truth number two a new and just
economy that does not address
generations of structural racism is not
a new and just economy
and as we've seen day in and day out
particularly over the last two years but
for generations the other side is more
than willing to talk about race
which means we spend our time talking
about race on defense
well i have never seen anybody win just
on defense
so we gotta pivot and say we're gonna go
on offense we're going to talk about
race
and when we envision a more just and
sustainable economy
it's going to be designed to address
generations of structural racism
so i got to go back to this slide see if
i can get this thing up there we go nice
so you know it's easy oh let's build a
movement here's the five-point plan
well i think what we want to think about
is how do you build the conditions for
movement and this is how we think about
it in national people's action
we think first you have to ground your
set and
yourself in a core set of ideas the
principles that will be at the
foundation of a movement
that'll form our moral compass to help
guide us moving forward
and we're talking about a shift
movements make a shift
to where their allegiance is to a set of
ideas not to one political party
and not to organizational affiliation
and until we make that shift put a stake
in the sand around a set of ideas
we will be pulled to political parties
because as we've seen
right now there is one big narrative and
one big idea that has traction in this
country
an anti-government big idea narrative
and it's not only pulling republicans to
the right
it's pulling democrats to the right so
we've got to get clear on what our ideas
are
second alignment effective movements
have major breakthroughs
in getting people to work together as
the progressive sector we have
lots of the capacities that we need to
actually do the right thing and to be
powerful and be effective
but at this point we're not working well
enough together so what would it look
like to
us have a serious plan to focus on
collaboration
on uh alignment around building a more
progressive and thoughtful
infrastructure
and focusing on more thoughtful uh
coordination
and the three biggest barriers we face
to this are credit control and money
that's where things break down between
organizations we want the credit we want
the control we want the money
well i don't think anywhere in anybody's
mission statement in this room does it
say
fight for credit control and money so
we've got to change that
third narrative the anti-government
narrative
that has traction in this country is one
of the biggest challenges we face
there's just no question about it laying
the biggest problems with the country at
the feet of government
has traction in this country and it is a
worldview fight that we have to
change so and i think this is one of the
biggest challenges to the new economy
that i think fader may have said it as
well as anybody
what is our inspiring compelling hopeful
narrative
about the economy and i think it needs
to include two things one
a critique around the current economy
and it has to have a critique around
free markets and corporations
and then secondly it has to have a
hopeful inspiring vision that people can
stick with for the long haul
because as we've found people will come
out join the fight
hit the streets initially out of anger
but they keep showing up year after year
out of hope
so we got to spell out the hope but the
main thing i want to focus on is
campaigns
because movements come out of action
and i think there are three things three
criteria we need to see in the kind of
campaigns and action that we move if
we're going to build a more just and
sustainable economy
and one we need to do things that expand
the realm of what's possible
too many of the fights we're engaged in
are about
winning as much as you can within the
margins as they are set
if the left is over here we're going to
push up against to the margin and do as
good as we can here and the right's
trying to push over here on this side of
the margin
but we need to blow up the margins we
need to do campaigns and do actions that
actually expand the realm of what's
possible
create new space for a new set of ideas
new ideas around strategy new ideas
around
tactics and new ideas around what the
future of the economy looks like because
right now
the ideas that we care so much about are
not on the table
secondly we have to make our problem
their problem i was just in iowa with
chris hayes of the nation speaking to a
bunch of family farmers
and chris laid out this an incredible
speech something we've always called
take the crisis to those who created it
but i think chris says it better
make our problem their problem tons of
people in this country are feeling an
economic crisis right now
tons of people but a small percentage is
completely immune from the crisis
they don't feel it in their gated
communities in their big buildings on
wall
street so we need to figure out how are
we going to take
the crisis to them how do we make our
problem their problem which means
going to people's homes which means
taking over their buildings
and putting new pressure on them and
thirdly we have to invest
in campaigns and actions that start at
the local level because if a look at
movement history
the great things that captured the
imagination of the american people
were not one big march or one big action
but they were actually
activities that created real struggle
and
unfolding drama that people could follow
day in
and day out and watch it like a soap
opera or watch it like the stock market
or watch it like their favorite sports
team and tune in so that's what we need
to do and then i want to come back
to our folks so here's an example of us
bringing the crisis to them
in 2008 you probably didn't hear about
this but we took
hundreds of people to ben bernanke's
house it was the week after they
uh bailed out bear stearns and we said
hey why don't you show the same vigor
that you're demonstrating and bailing
out bear stearns to begin to bail out
the american people so we went to his
home
we actually weren't 100 sure was it was
his address but as we got off the bus
and security jumped out of bushes we
said okay this is somebody bad did
something here
we've got somebody bad lives here so it
was good and it was bernanke's house
we then took 500 people to his office
the next day were met by armed security
but the end of the story is we've had
three negotiating meetings with chairman
bernanke
that every day poor people from across
this country have sat across from the
man
and the board of governors and pushed
him to do more to hold banks accountable
so making our problem their problem
works
secondly mitzi river singleton who you
saw earlier who got screwed by a payday
lender
well mitzi and 5000 people came to the
uh
chicago for the american bankers
association they were having their
convention to celebrate all their great
achievements
well we decided we needed to crash this
party they were not coming to our city
we're headquartered in chicago we had to
crash this party
and one of the great stories was brenda
leblanc another 81 year old retiree from
iowa
she took 200 people past security
because they went down
they put their sunday best on and our
folks sunday best is not
does not look like banker wear but we
got through security and went down to
michigan avenue
and got more uh nordstrom bags banana
republic bags
and gucci bags we didn't buy anything we
just asked for the bags
and we walked straight through security
took over the lobby
occupied the building and put a new
level of pressure on the bankers we made
our problem their problem
and then here trenda kennedy who still
to this day is fighting to save her home
she led 750 everyday people to the
uh the home of a bank of america
executive it's kind of scary to do that
that's like breaking the be nice rule
the rules in society say you don't do
that
but we say hey bank of america comes to
the homes of everyday people
every single day and it's not pretty so
we're coming to you
and then these are just actions that
we've done and this is the kind of
activity that we're going to need to put
a new level of pressure
on those who've created the crisis so i
want to close with this
you build movements through a long-term
plan you build movements
through long-term thinking but today
if we want to change things for the
mitzi's for the ferals and for the
trenders we need the right now plan
and the right now plan starts with
moving people to action the right now
plan means tapping into a progressive
populist sentiment that is a simmer at
this moment
but we can blow it up into a boil the
right now man
plant means creating the arena for
people to move to action
to tune into their sense of somebodiness
and put a new level of pressure on those
who created the crisis we face today
thank you
okay so we're down to our final speaker
and
thank you guys all for being here and
hanging in this has been a really great
session i hope that you've enjoyed
it our next speaker and our final
speaker is deepak bhargava
deepak is executive director of center
for community change based in washington
d.c
he is a very inspiring leader to me um i
know him and i think he's great and he's
been at the center of the fight for
social justice and economic justice
policy change for over a decade most
recently he's been very active in the
fight for immigration reform
and for job creation he really is one of
the rising stars of the movement
and he has a great gift of kind of
wrapping it all together and breaking it
all down and so
i know you're going to love what he has
to say right now thanks a lot and
welcome deepak
good afternoon everybody
so i'm getting the feeling that one of
the main criteria for getting to speak
at netroots this is my first
is a prominent position on the glenn
beck wall
so i'm a little concerned about my own
status
for a while i was to the right of van
jones to the left of valerie jarrett and
underneath mount saitung
but i think i'm dropping so i'm hoping
my performance today kind of helps boost
my
boost my ratings so i'm deepak bhargava
i'm a community organizer and i'm proud
of it
what i'm going to try to do today i'm
going to try out some new material with
you today
is to talk about what might be some
principles
for a long-term progressive economic
vision
but before i do that i do want to talk
about a couple of things in the here and
now
so john maynard keynes the great
economist once said when
he was told that experts were expressing
confidence that in the long run
the economy would return to equilibrium
and full employment
kane said in the long run we're all dead
so we do live in a massive economic
crisis
and the first thing i want to say is we
need jobs desperately
we need a lot of them and we need them
right now
now the good news is we actually know
how to do this
we have had the experience in our
history of the 1930s with the works
progress administration the civilian
conservation corps
in the 1970s on a smaller scale with the
ceta program
and today there's a proposal that my
organization has been working on
uh that congressman george miller is
sponsored with 160 co-sponsors in the
house
that would create a hot would create a
million jobs a year for two years
for people to do useful work in
communities
greening the economy taking care of our
kids educating our kids
refurbishing schools and senator brown
sherrod brown is sponsored in the senate
we have the capacity in in the great
depression hundreds of thousands of jobs
were created in the span of months by
fdr and harry hopkins his key aid
in a time when there weren't it wasn't
the level of federal bureaucracy and
infrastructure that there is today
so we absolutely have the capacity to do
it and we should
the second thing i want to say is i want
to challenge you and ask you all
to join me and many many other
organizations who are calling a major
mobilization in washington
on october 2nd 2010 called the one
nation march
now i'm asking you to do this not just
because marching is fun
and i do think marching is fun but
because at this moment it is of great
strategic
importance there is a kind of malaise
and despondency and dispiritedness in
many parts of the progressive world
we have been barely able to get an
unemployment benefits extension through
the united states senate
let alone the kinds of ambitious wpa
style programs that i'm suggesting that
we really need to get the economy moving
without major mobilization we will not
be able
to turn the politics around on the
economy in this country so i want you to
come and to promote
10 to 10 as a major event
so let me move on to talk about the long
run so i work at the center for
community change whose mission is
to spur and support grassroots
organizing mostly in poor communities
and in communities of color
and we've done some great things over
the years but the hard truth of the
matter is
that the last 40 years since my
organization was founded in 1968
we've been living in a period of
retrenchment and reaction
on some basic issues of racial justice
of economic justice the gains of the new
deal the great society the civil rights
movement
have been steadily eroded over that
period of time
we've had a couple of important
victories in this last two years
uh the stimulus program the recovery act
though it's not
widely understood was the largest
expansion of anti-poverty programs in
this country in 40 years
the health care bill was the largest
redistribution
redistributive program in this country
in 40 years and the largest expansion of
the safety net
but the hard truth remains that for the
people who are the reason for my
organization's existence
life is worse not better we have 20
percent unemployment in communities of
color
in this country in some neighborhoods
it's a catastrophic levels of 50 percent
or higher
we have rising poverty extreme poverty
child poverty
increasing hunger increasing
homelessness there is immense
suffering in the united states of
america and
the brutal fact is that there's almost
nothing
in the mainstream economic or political
discourse today that would do a damn
thing about
that's the hard reality we start from
so in light of the seriousness of this
predicament
i want to take a crack at trying to
define what might that long-term vision
for a progressive economics in this
country be and i start from the premise
that we carry an albatross around our
necks
which is free market fundamentalism an
ideology that is so pervasive
that it is like the air we breathe and
the water we swim in we barely recognize
it
and as the british historian uh perry
anderson
said without a conceptual alternative
across the full range from the
philosophical to the technical to the
rally political
we will not be able to break through and
make progress
and some questions in our society have
been actually put beyond the pale of
acceptable discourse how much
wealth is too much wealth how much
inequality
is okay these questions are barely asked
anymore in our society and it was
not always so and it is also the case
that this is not just a problem of
conservative
ideology when a democratic president as
bill clinton
did signed welfare reform and destroyed
the safety net for poor families in this
country
and signed nafta to send millions of
american jobs overseas and at the same
time manage to impoverish
mexican people on the land in mexico
fueling the immigration that we see now
in our country
you know that this ideology is pervasive
and it is possible that in 2011 we will
have a fight
not just with republicans but with
democrats about saving and preserving
social security
so we have a deep deep ideological
problem
and i think that fighting these fights
simply on
issue grounds trade over here deficits
over there
safety nets over here jobs over there is
not sufficient to the task at hand
that the place to begin is at the level
of fundamental principles
now we all know the conservative
principles that operate through each and
every issue fight
that we see in congress and around the
country that
human beings are basically selfish that
competition
is the currency of american life that
wealth is created
principally by individual entrepreneurs
who are heroic
and that we all benefit when they do
well
that free markets are the best way to
organize an economy
that smallest government is the best
government
that we live in a colorblind society and
that racism is essentially
a thing of the past as we say as we new
yorkers say
forget about it what's an alternative
what's a path forward so i want to lay
out six potential
principles that we might think about and
some of these i hope will be a little
provocative
so first that wealth is not created
by individual heroic entrepreneurs
but wealth is created by all of us
so that activities that we sometimes
think about is
marginal or irrelevant economic
production scholarship
art science child care care giving these
are in fact
fundamentally constitutive of the
project of wealth building
so sometimes liberals will say well the
market system is the best we got we got
to support those entrepreneurs
but let's just take a little bit of that
money and give it to the poorest people
because the outcomes are so unfair
what i'm proposing is a different view
which is not that
they are the uh geese that lay the
golden eggs but that in fact
wealth is created by everyone in our
society that we all have a contribution
to it
and that we all therefore have a moral
stake in wealth
that is not a matter of charity that it
is a matter of recognition
of the productivity of workers of
communities of everybody and creating
wealth
second principle our shared
quality of life is more important than
the private accumulation of wealth
so sometimes the pursuit of private
accumulation of wealth serve social ends
and in that case it should be rewarded
but the speculative frenzy of the
housing bubble
uh the subprime crisis the ma the
excessive salaries and bonuses of
executives
this is not fundamentally productive
activity
capital that was locked up in lavish
mansions
in luxury vehicles and financial
speculation could have been used for
education
for transportation for clean energy and
other investments
that would have laid the groundwork for
long-term growth private wealth should
be respected
but it is not sacrosanct
third human beings are complex
and they are not exclusively driven by
selfishness
now progressives are not naive we don't
assume that people are always good
we did live with dick cheney for eight
years right so we have some evidence of
the contrary but we do assert and new
science backs this up that people
are capable of acting morally and with
care and compassion
for one another we are also unapologetic
in asserting that we have
obligations deep moral obligations
to one another to act and behave as
though other people
count as much as we do from these
principles we would generate a pretty
powerful critique of what's going on in
our country
today is it okay that some people are
walking around with a three million
dollar
gold ipod while other people are living
lives of quiet and invisible desperation
in our society
i think it's a moral outrage
and i think these kinds of behaviors of
the excess of wealth
are fundamentally sociopathic
they are destructive of a good society
and they ought to be condemned and
subject to cultural critique
fourth inequality
in wealth and income beyond a certain
point and we crossed this point long ago
in the united states
is destructive not just of democracy and
of a sense of a common project
but it also undermines the prospects of
a well-functioning economy that is to
say
more equality is good for
growth for a functioning
economy and that the inequality that
we've seen is not only
excessive bad on moral grounds
it actually undermines the conditions
for a good economy
fifth racial inequality is not a
separate issue from economic inequality
they are part and parcel of the same set
of structures that operate in the united
states of america
and any progressive project on economic
inequality given the
vast disparities of wealth and income
that we still see
will have to put racial justice at the
center of the project
last principle broader participation
by workers by community members is
good for economic productivity for
economic efficiency and therefore
we have a stake in promoting collective
organization of workers in unions and
supporting the efforts of community
organizers to build constituencies to
bargain for people
to struggle for a better life it is not
in against an opposition to a
well-functioning economy
it is actually a requirement of a
well-functioning economy
so if we took these values seriously
what might it imply
for an economic agenda for the country
well it would suggest that we might
still have
markets as a dominant feature of our
economic paradigm
but that we would structure those market
in such a way that they aligned with
social values
that might mean much higher standards
labor standards with respect to wages
and working conditions
sick days and paid vacation as
congressman grayson said
it might mean luxury taxes and estate
taxes so we don't see
outrageous concentrations of wealth it
might ask us
it might call on us to ask hard
questions
about the corporation and its role in
american life
the corporation is a relatively modern
invention
it did not come from god it is capable
of being
changed and reformed charter reforms
putting workers and community members on
boards
requiring there to be means of corporate
accountability greater regulation
all of these things become possible to
imagine
if we start from a different set of
values fundamentals
so i want to turn
finally to the issue that george engaged
george gale engaged so well
which is the question of social movement
because in american history shifts from
one set of values and principles to
another
have not come mainly through academic
exercises they have come
because millions of ordinary people have
taken history
into their own hands in the populist
movement
in the workers movements of the 1930s
and so forth so and the
projects of having an intellectual
agenda and ideas agenda on the one hand
and having a movement strategy on the
other are closely intertwined and linked
because if we don't have a story that we
believe in we can't build
a mass army for these changes but if we
don't have
a movement in the country we won't have
the power and we won't have the ideas
and the passion and the energy
from the grassroots to get it done so
i've had the luxury and the privilege
over the last
uh 10 years of being part of the
immigrant rights movement and i've
learned two things from that
one is that you've got a dream big when
we started no one thought that
legalizing 12 million undocumented
people was remotely feasible and not a
single person in the beltway wanted to
talk about it
similarly these kinds of economic
questions are going to need to be put on
the table
secondly we're going to need
organizations at scale
unions community groups perhaps new
forms of organization that we can't even
imagine today
to create the power and the engine for
those reforms
so let me just say in wrapping up that
um
i know this has seemed like this seems
in a way like a very perilous time
for the country and it is not going to
be easy to get some of the kinds of
reforms that were talked about here
today
but the truth is if it was easy it would
not be worthy of the progressive promise
because the progressive promise is
basically about keeping faith with the
unemployed worker in detroit the single
mom in fresno
the immigrant worker at a meat plant in
omaha with the belief
and the conviction that they are not
simply victims
but that we need their talent their
inspiration
linked together with all of us to build
a better america and we can do it and we
will do it
thank you very much
okay hi i've acquired a growth because
my husband had to go to his session this
is marco
and i think he's the youngest net roost
nation attendee ever
he's eight weeks um so anyway that's it
you guys thank you so much it was great
to have everybody here and thank you to
all the speakers who came and gave us
such
great food for thought thanks a lot take
care